l'ukraine qui a fait resurgir le spectre
d'une guerre atomique en europe un
conflit auquel la suisse se prépare
depuis longtemps ici vous allez le voir
chaque habitant dispose d'une place dans
un abri bétonné sous terre une pratique
issue de la guerre froide et qui revient
au goût du jour marc pop
sous ces immeubles de béton au milieu
des montagnes la suisse cultive à cinq
ici une loi du début des années 60 rend
obligatoire la construction d'abris
bétonner le principe une place pour
chaque habitant chaque habitant doit
avoir sa place protégée est donc sous
chaque immeuble de cet éco quartier il y
à des abris privés et il ya aussi pour
les écoles ou autres l'abri des abris
publics de plus de 300 places et c'est
vraiment dédié au quartier à la
population locale pour les protéger à
l'intérieur tout est prévu pour vivre
confortablement
on y trouve des lits superposés des
douches des salles de commandement ou
encore des hôpitaux tout pour survivre
en cas de conflit un peu tombé dans
l'oubli ces dernières années voir
menacée par l'assemblée fédérale du pays
la guerre en ukraine a réveillé
l'intérêt des habitants pour ses
constructions on se rend compte qu'il ya
des centrales nucléaires en suisse à des
centrales nucléaires en europe à
plusieurs endroits donc oui cette
utilité ça a été conçu pour ça et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on doit les garder
en tout cas avec ce qui se passe dans le
monde on doit les garder en état de
préparation le pays compte ainsi
365000 abris privés et publics pouvant
accueillir près de 9 millions de
personnes mais de fortes différences
régionales subsistent genève par exemple
est particulièrement sous dotées avec un
taux de couverture d'environ 75%